pop
[Musique]
avez vous lu les prophéties de
nostradamus oui enfin j'ai essayé
c'était en 1940 on me l'avait passé sous
le manteau étrange destin n'est ce pas
que celui de ce livre de ce livre dont
napoléon disait qu'y l'épouvanté irrite
tout à la fois l'imagination et qui fut
dit en le livre de chevet de quelques
autres grands ou petits capitaine mais
seulement quand venait pour eux l'heure
du doute et des désillusions
car les ceintures in de stradibus si le
nom de leur auteur est universellement
connus ne sont un best seller que
lorsque le monde semble rouler vers le
gouffre et la catastrophe
il en est ainsi depuis plus de quatre
siècles et le paradoxe c'est que chacun
vaque été un peu d'espoir dans ce
millier de 4,1 énigmatique plein de
bruit et de fureur
parce que beaucoup trouvent un certain
réconfort dans l'idée que notre avenir
est des a voulu et déterminée et que dès
lors les épreuves de demain doivent
avoir leur sens et leur utilité
les sans doute aussi parce que
l'incertitude est la pire cause de nos
angoisses et que savoir de quoi demain
sera fait même si demain prend des
couleurs d'apocalypse vaut mieux qu
avant c est dans la nuit oui mais ne
sera dame us savait-il de quoi demain
serait fait ça c'est toute la question
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
derrière justin cher ou un char à l'est
dépêchez vous cette fois vous avez
entendu mais n'en sais rien babbitt et
moi je suis sortir de la faillite on
travaille
il n'y a plus rien je vous ai tous passé
et cette plaque qui brille ça c'est du
cuivre rage toujours à l'avant malheur à
toi qui aux profs à delémont sépulcre le
jour de ton sacrilège sera celui de ta
mort
[Musique]
citoyens ils ont violé toi bonne fin
d'année
[Musique]
oh
qu'attendez vous de nous vénérable frère
vous me disiez dans votre sagesse
si vous pensez comme moi que le temps
est venu de donner à publier le livre de
mes prophétie comment se présentera cet
ouvrage dix chapitres comprenant 100
prédictions chacun j'appellerai les
centuries je signerai du nom de
nostradamus
en quelle langue et il a rédigé en
langue vulgaire mais les de latin et de
grec assez obscure pour que le sens
demeure cachée est assez claire pour
qu'il se laisse deviner quand
l'événement commence d'advenir ses
productions sont lbp je pourrais donner
l'année le mois et le jour de chacune
mais là réside le secret que dieu veut
et je n'en ferai rien il se peut qu'un
jour pour le bonheur la paix
l'accomplissement de l'homme qui sont
les fins de notre société nous vous
demandions d'offrir certaines vérités
plus clairement à ceux qui détiennent le
pouvoir
vous en jugerez vénérable maître c'est
bien vous pouvez publier votre livre je
le serai au plus vite
il songe dû mettre autant de l'une des
plus tragiques de mes premières
prophéties sur le point de s'accomplir
juillet 15 159 le traité du cateau
cambrésis vient de mettre fin à la
guerre qui opposait la france à
l'espagne et l'angleterre pour fêter la
paix retrouvée le roi henri ii est la
reine catherine de médicis donne de
grandes festivités au château des
tourneurs
on organise des tournois leroy
l'emportent sur le duc de savoie le duc
de guise
un nouvel adversaire se présente
montgomerie capitaine de sa garde
écossaise pour la troisième fois le roi
abaisse la visière de son casque d'or
xinhua
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de chergé dur moi où est le danger du
mois revient sur moi a reçu un coup
d'oeil aux visages dans les touchés par
des éclats de bois dont le n est rien de
vital madame une simple cavités qui la
joue lundi nous guérirons le roi
personne ne doit hanter
[Musique]
vous n'attendez point d'autres nouvelles
les plus lourds s adonnent envoyé un
courrier portero doj de nouvelle de la
mort du roi de france d'amour
l'ambassadeur denise entendre a dit
l'appétit mieux que le chien du roi
pourquoi monsieur les gars mais c'est
peut-être mieux lire et j'ai pas de
mémoire au bout
que voulez vous dire vous rappelez vous
ce si le lion jeunes le vieux surmontera
enchante velits par duel singulier dans
cage d'or les yeux lui crèvera deux
classes une puis mourir mort cruelle
c'est dans la première century des
prophéties de nostradamus
[Musique]
qu'est ce que je ferais la cour jaligny
je ne sais pourquoi les grands se place
sous des ciels bruit et d'humidité
regardez regardez et chevigny ce
firmament les huiles provence vous
montre le corps céleste comme avec une
loupe et ses étoiles vous parle plus
fort qu'à aucun moment je les entends
gémir crier pleurer de toute la misère
des hommes n'est jamais rire ou chanter
non la joie j'ai fini mes poils à faire
des prophètes mieux voir et donc mieux
comprendre les mouvements des astres qui
ordonne le sort des humains c'est dont
l'atout votre secret ignorer privilège
que pour un astrologue mené lettre vous
pas et le plus grand est notre maître à
tous et non non non pas vous mon ami pas
vous qui avez si bien si vous lire qui
est devenu jusqu'à ma plein de bonne
compréhension astrologues
dieu m'est témoin je ne suis point ou si
peu
le moindre de vos discours sur ce sujet
me serais une leçon ou mode comment vous
avez étudié cette science à l'université
de paris vous avez été l'élève de
l'immortel jean doral et moi j'en ai
étudié à montpellier que ce qu'un bon
médecin doit savoir pour deviner les
épidémies ou connaître les jours le
temps fera que les humeurs seront
mauvaises ou les médecines efficace
alors tout ce que vous savez tout ce que
vous avez lu du destin qui nous attend
nous et nos enfants et les enfants de
nos enfants
feriez-vous koné non point par science
mais par
achevée
toute la ville doit dormir ou presque
qui pourrait vous entends la révocation
diabolique
pardonnez moi je n'aurais pas dû dire
cela mais j'ai tant de vénération porn
que même jusque là je pourrais vous
suivre jusqu'en enfer je sais bien c'est
ce que voulait dire je crois que rien de
mauvais ne peut venir d'un homme tel que
vous si telle est la volonté de dieu et
les voies du seigneur chavigny par est
bien tortueuse opposé ce prix nous
sommes mais puisque je ne puis vous
détourner de cette étrange idée de
vouloir écrire l'histoire de ma vie
il faut donc je me raconte à vous et par
le commencement
ah si je vous disais quel est le premier
présent qu'il m'a fait pour pouvoir un
jour se servir de moi perdre le goût le
besoin du sommeil
les nuits me sont devenues comme les
jours c'est peut-être un peu moins de
force
peut-être un peu plus de fièvre mais
nulle autre différence alors j'ai pris
l'habitude de monter jusqu ici et de
jouer avec ce grand grouillement des
toiles comme d'autres avec un jeu
d'échecs n'était soi de l'astrologie
peut-être alors mais ce n'était pas mon
vrai propos il ne suffisait pas savoir
si les constellations les maisons et les
planètes s'harmonisaient ou s'opposer
j'ai toujours si profondément ressenti
la toute puissance divine qu'il me
semblait bien que ce miroir de l'homme
ils pouvaient le déformer sa guise mais
plus bouger dans l'éternel mémoire de
dieu voit la corrège vous vous dites est
l'ambition démesurée pour ce petit homme
vous auriez même le droit de penser
quelle folie c'est que vous ne savez pas
encore touché ligne est pas encore tout
[Musique]
montré ma femme rangée qu'elle est ce
que tu là vous déranger joaillier m'ont
fait avec un autre guichet que le pardon
il était totale et rapide
le nom de la ville et je vois que vous
passez le temps à de savants des bons
valables il fait bien chaud sous les
combles et votre vin s y ferait le
premier consul désire vous parlions le
premier consul où il vous attend en bas
dans la salle d'un secteur probablement
quelques accidents dans sa famille bon
je viens ma compagne et vous cheminez
j'ai fait une longue route aujourd'hui
je n'ai pas reçu la grâce de pouvoir me
priver dormir si vous le permettez je
m'ennuie à leurs amis et à demain des
étoiles n'auront pas changé de place
vient de suite eh bien monsieur le
premier consul point de trauma leur
respect non non non non grâce à dieu
rien de tel n'est pourtant pas une aire
pour annoncer une bonne nouvelle
je vous prie de m'excuser je sortais du
conseil en passant devant chez vous j'ai
vu des chandelles qui brûlait aux étages
et madame votre épouse qui prenait
encore le ferait sur le seuil
je viens demander si je pouvais vous
parlez fait le nom puisqu'il nous a dit
que oui il a beaucoup été question de
vous à ce conseil il faut vous dire que
nous y avons appris une nouvelle
d'importance est sans doute la
connaissez vous déjà peut-être peut-être
le roi doit venir prochainement en
provence la reine-mère des amis faire
connaître son royaume pourquoi les
princes ne faut-il pas aussi le tour de
france en réalité il s'agit de
réaffirmer dans les régions les plus
troublées la nouvelle politique de
tolérance religieuse et de bonne entente
entre catholiques nos qui ne s'en
réjouirait bien sûr bien sûr si vous
désirez quelques devises versifiée en
l'ananas et auguste visite vous voudrez
bien attendre jusqu'à demain comme sans
doute sans doute il nous faudra de ces
compliments bien tourner donc vous avez
le secret mais salon de croo n'est pas
tout la provence et rien ne dit que le
roi passera par notre ville assez
paisible somme toute vous finirez par le
regretté au le ciel m'en préserve
enfin le conseil unanime à penser que
vous pourriez peut-être intercéder
auprès de leurs majestés pour qu'elle
fasse halte dans notre cité
le conseil unanime à mon sujet
m comment donc je puis vous jurer mais
pourquoi moi grands dieux mais qui
d'autre pourrait le faire avait plus de
raisons que vous la famille royale vous
a toujours grandement honoré
j'ai passé quelques semaines en prenne
la reine et du feu roi henri ii de grâce
écrivez la lettre que je vous demande
faites-le pour notre bonne ville team en
aura mille reconnaissance j'y compte
bien mais pourquoi tant d'amertume nous
tous ici vous le savez avant pour votre
science la plus grande admiration
mais certains membres de votre beau
constat et ce signe avant de franchir ma
porte pour prendre médecine au long
monsieur de nostredame la grandeur de
votre pouvoir a bien de quoi rendre
productif
quelques esprits superstitieux et
hargneux quelques esprits mesquins jolie
population à vérité au sein de laquelle
je me sens aussi choyés quand guillon
friture hier encore des gens à moi m'ont
apporté de faux almanac portant mon nom
et contenant me l'ineptie imprimés pour
me discréditer
mettez donc un terme à tant de
fripouilles monsieur le consul et je
verrai bien alors si les habitants de
salon mérite que juste pour eux un
morceau de papier
monsieur de nostredame vous savez que je
fais tout ce qui est en mon pouvoir
- de même monsieur le consul moi de même
je vous souhaite une bonne nuit
mais monsieur de nostredame
encore un mot de passe
on dit que la reine good for toutes les
sciences gastronomiques sans doute avant
et un découvrir le ciel depuis votre
magnifique observatoire bonne nuit ils
veulent continuer à nuire monsieur de
nostredame
elle vole à mon ami
[Musique]
copé quand même bien
ma femme il vous faudra faire blanchir
passé non plus belles dentelles le petit
roi qu'on va venir nous rendre visite
avec la reine-mère peut-être même chez
nous qui nous fait nous laver une
catherine et le rôle ici qu'elle est
aussi de se dire votre ennemi reste à
pétrifier brouillon apportez moi plutôt
de l'encré du paquet et trouvez moi un
exemple bien imprimer mon dernier
almanach je vais l'écrire cette lettre
pour que tu puisse dire un jour le roi
de france est venu dans la maison de mon
père mon fils tu n es trop tard pour
bien me remettre quand tu seras un homme
jean déjà quitté ce monde c'est pour toi
aussi que j'ai accepté notre ami
chavigny écrit l'histoire de ma vie en
la lisant
tu pourras découvrir et faire comprendre
aux autres qui étaient en perds tu
serais un beau papillon monter un grand
papillon qui sortira tout neuf du cocon
longuement filets par la vieille race de
monstres mais ça nous pendait lui c'est
un château mais voilà près de dix ans
que vous rabâcher la même chose voilà
près de dix ans que je vous répète comme
tels qu'alain koffi bon faiseur de rois
l'astral le voulons madame pour votre
vie vous mais pour tout le reste un
homme disant pour l'être toujours là nos
points madame je vous en demande mais
pardon il y a dix ans à la lecture du
charabia de ce provençal
je me doutais qu'il n'y avait là comme
mauvaise poésie phrases creuses et mou
vide de sens aujourd'hui j'en ai la
certitude et pourquoi non mais parce que
durant toutes ces années j'ai tourné
retourner chaque 4 1 chaque verre pour y
déceler quelques lumières sur l'avenir
je n'ai trouvé que tenait oubliez-vous
dans la mort du roi en époux si
clairement annoncé triste message du
hasard d'un rien de plus d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce qu'un présage quand il n'est
point daté c'est à vous de les dater
savait bien qu'il existe un moyen c'est
vous le connaissez madame je vous
supplie de blanc singh
nostradamus lui même nous en a donné les
clés en évoquant une certaine
chronologie dans la préface qu'il
écrivait pour le roi il en évoque même
deux qui soi-disant se référant à la
bible et qui toutes deux sont fous ce
monsieur lavis bernardi ne me contredira
pas s'ils les examiner les plus
éminentes au logis hommes donneront
raison
la vérité valable c'est que ce le
stradale us est plus rusé que le diable
est plus tendue que l'enfer la vérité
c'est que ce médecin doit connaître
quelques science que vous ignorent oui
j'ai pensé qu'il n'avait pu se servir
des secrets drague le bal pour brouiller
l'ordre il le sens de ses prédictions
voilà pourquoi j'ai demandé l'aide de
monsieur d'armor la lumière
pourrait-elle nous unit dans un aussi
jeune les plus sages vous diront qu'en
matière de sion et langue hébraïque
monsieur tard mme hautala plus besoin de
mer et geoffrey si vous le permettez
madame un autre mot vert est calé dans
votre avis
il est vrai madame parce que la vérité
n'existe point de longs discours n'est 4
ha de nostradamus ne sont que ce qu'ils
sont ce qu'ils sont témoigne d'une
grande confusion de penser et d'un
certain mépris de la langue française
c'est d'inventer pour adb vous l'avez
pas de sens
[Musique]
beaucoup
je vends pièce madame et nous allons
manquer les meilleurs genre de choses
partons le roi sera encore meilleur
chasseur que sa mère qui d'autre que lui
le pourrait si la chose est possible et
pour salons de croo que décidé vous
madame
nous irons bien sûr porterez vous même
la réponse à la lettre de monsieur de
nostredame vous lui direz que je serais
personnellement heureuse s'il nous fait
les honneurs de son observatoire est ce
bien utile
après ce que nous venons d'entendre
lorsque monsieur de nostredame est venu
au château de blois il a prédit que mes
quatre fils règnerait le roi est mort
comme il l'avait prévu
le dauphin renier et il est mort comme
il l'avait prévu
premier fils malheureux mariage sans
nulle enfants deux îles en dix corps
avant dix-huit un compétiteur et notre
bien-aimé françois ii est mort avant ses
18 ans et l'union avec la pauvre mari
style arrêté mort hystérique tant de
pression ce de quoi surprendre
et cette bête condal fille qui parle de
hasard aujourd'hui charles règne et la
prophétie continue de s'accomplir
on avait rempli de joie
elle me terrifie j'imaginais quatre
couronnes et les fûts ce que je donnais
ou valoir m 2 4 au royaume et s'il n'en
était rien si chacun devait prendre la
couronne offrons un frère mort madame
méthyle singer chrétiens de chercher à
savoir si dieu veut à tout prix placé
des sceptres entre les mains de mes
enfants je le retrouverai tendre ça
défoule étrange prédictions de monsieur
de nostredame pour ce jour il nous
conseille de ne plus attendre pour
planter les fêtes approchent et braves
gens approcher ceux qui ont déjà lu les
traits savone pronostics à sion de
monsieur nostradamus savent de quoi les
saisons seront faites mais vous ignorant
du taux des jours propices et des
comètes porteuse de troubles organiques
vous allez comme des petits enfants tous
nus dans la neige comme des chevaliers
guerroyant sans armure comme des bateaux
privés de ramener de voile et pourquoi
pourquoi parce que vous gardez un sol
dans votre choix un pauvre petit somme
qui vous permettrait de retrouver nobles
dames la peau douce et blanche de vos
jeunes années à tout petit sol mais sur
laboureur pour savoir s'il est trop tôt
pour planter des fèves ou trop tard pour
les tomates
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un seul mot gentilhomme pour apprendre à
confectionner d'un faillible dragées
d'amour
mais c'est pas moche ça chez moi place
et doit ainsi moi
là
ne fuyez pas mais très je suis là pour
vous apporter la sainte parole de dieu
pour aider il est bon et pio catholique
que vous êtes avance à tâtons et ses
ministres
écouter ce que disent les écrits qui ont
été arrêtés les suspendre quel bac ou
jacques il fait baisser l'euro face à va
nous faire connaître l'étendue des
moments et ceux qui tentent d'arracher
au tout-puissant ses secrets par magic
diabolique par interne à l'astrologie
cela m'évite et de périr dans les
flammes
il nous les brûlerons de demain devant
les portes de la cette maison de dieu
comme nous brûlons aujourd'hui leur
seule remontée des barbares les russes
très estimable que les bêtes sauvages
allez-vous utilement perd pas c'est moi
la charpie mon chien il a devant vous
sur la deuxième étage hier voilà ce sont
vos paroissiens les brutes
si je n'avais pas des liens aussi
profond que le mariage pour m'attacher à
cette ville je préférais aller soigner
les turcs ou les mongols je n'ai pas vu
le visage de cette sorte de capucins
mais je puis vous affirmer que les deux
autres n'étaient pas gens d'ici et des
lâches des lâches par dessus le marché
qui vont recruter dans les tripots d'aix
ou de marseille des spadassins pour
l'heure plus vils besogne non non mon
fils que vous fassiez des jaloux je ne
le sait que trop que quelques confrères
écrit vous égratignez à coups de plume
ce n'est que trop vrai mais 20 violence
les coups impossibles
non vous ne vous ne m'enlèverez pas que
l'idée que ça vient d'ailleurs donné mon
père vous fait rire pour les purs le mal
vient toujours d'ailleurs mekkid on
s'inquiéterait de moi ailleurs cet
onguent est souverain et bono mal jusque
dans les racines dans deux jours tu
pourrais reprendre la route et je te
donnerai de nouveau à main n'a sûrement
pas monsieur le scellement préserve tu
trompes endurer aujourd'hui pour me
risquer à nouveau est tu n'auras qu'à
être sur ses gardes
à vous de le dire je me suis fait lire
vos pronostics à sion pour ce mardi
c'était jour faste demande à ceux qui
t'ont roucoule il ne me démentiront pas
va alors tu prendras avec toi quelques
bus seront munies d'un bon gourdin je le
paierai peut-être serait-il plus sage
d'attendre quelques temps et monsieur le
curé et oubliez vous qu'à chaque mois
qui passe il me faudra battre le prix
d'un douzième voyons monsieur de
nostredame vous êtes un bourgeois ils ne
seraient plus longtemps le nombre des
miséreux que vous m'envoyez chaque jour
ne cesse de grandir
vous êtes bien l'homme le plus généreux
de cette ville la main du pauvre et la
bourse de dieu monsieur le curé
jour faste il m'insulte comme hérétique
demain le pourchasserons comme sorciers
moi qui me suis toujours comporté comme
le plus fidèle des fidèles de la seule
église romaine moi qui n'ai jamais
manqué une messe ni sauter un répond
personnellement pas prudent soit finie
mais par un profond besoin mais le monde
est ainsi fait que toute vertu peut se
retourner contre celui la pratique qui
pourrait douter de votre foi on voudra
voir hypocrisie là où il n'y a que
recherche angoisses et quelques rentes
vous pousse à toujours plus de zèle les
esprits qui comme les nôtres cherche au
delà des connaissances communes sont
toujours en péril et le diable guette
dès qu'on passe l'habituel mesure quand
je vous disais l'autre nuit mon grand
rêve de connaître ce que nous cache la
barrière du temps ne pensez-vous pas
orgueil et folie j'avais pour espérer de
toute autre raison
dès ma plus tendre enfance j'ai connu
cette sorte de prédestination mon aïeul
marc est enseigné la longue histoire de
notre famille nous sommes les
descendants de la grande tribu d'isaca à
laquelle du avait donné pour prix de sa
sagesse le don de prophétiser je
comprends maintenant pourquoi vous
refusez ce titre d'astrologues prophète
vous l'êtes par votre sens et non par
calcul astronomique
oui la science vient après elle confirme
elle offre quelques points de repère
pour s'assurer que ces pointes égaré en
chemin
ainsi vous étiez comme un saint en
extase qui attend le miracle cette
armoire était tout empli de livres les
ancêtres n'avaient l'aîné
j'ai commencé à vouloir connaître
l'avenir dans ces traités plein de magie
et puis un jour j'ai compris que je
devais les brûler ce n'est qu'après que
les visions sont venus comme si le
tout-puissant n'attendaient que de voir
tout mon être débarrassé de
connaissances un pur pour m'offrir sa
vérité et à partir de ce jour sont
apparus les images des temps et jour
après jour le lendemain s'appuyant sur
la veille l'aube sur une bêtise
j'ai vu la france déchirée shalini
catholiques et huguenots ses gorges ans
sans merci et les plus grands par cole
les pieds pendu j'ai vu mourir le roi
est le fils du roi devenu roi et
l'enfant roi d'aujourd'hui comme pris de
folie ordonnant le massacre tout autour
du louvre et son petit frère grandir
pour monter sur le trône se faire à sa
seule à blois les périr éventrée j'ai vu
mourir tous les rois de france jamais
menée jusqu'au dernier et ce sera la fin
des temps
juste la fin du temps des roses elle y
affirmait la monarchie qui règne real le
peuple comme dans les cités antiques le
peuple lui-même se gouvernera lors at il
voulu dans le sang et par la violence
voulez vous dire qu il chassera ou pire
encore le dernier de nos rois
connaissez-vous un village du nom de
varennes ne me semble pas mieux j'ai
cherché il existe plusieurs lieux de ce
nom c'est dans l'un d'eux que se nouera
le tragique destin du dernier des grands
capétiens voilà dans le sens de ces vers
de nuit viendra par la forêt des reines
le moins de noirs en gris dedans
varennes cause tempête
et ensuite le pape ira t-il seul son
chemin ou bien plus de temps
souvenez-vous les rouges rouges rouges
assommeront né dans la confusion
il se choisiront qui nous vaut un
empereur naître un prêt d'italie qui à
l'en pire sera vendu bien cher et par
lui l'europe entière
ra de boucherie en boucherie et c'est
aigle qui se voulait le maître du monde
vaincus finira ses jours sur un petit
morceau de terre lointaine lieu bien
infime d'exide du comté ou au milieu
viendra poser son sceptre et après on
verra revenir des rois son pouvoir
le neveu de l'empereur et les gens du
commun reprendront en main leur destin
et encore après
après
après tout devient aussi différents les
mots me manquent le plus souvent pour
montrer ce que j'ai vu vous garderez
secrètes ses révélations n'est ce pas
chavigné vous n'en parlerais pas dans
votre livre
il faut que la sentence demeure
énigmatique pour que rien ne vienne
nuire à son accomplissement m'en
veuillez pas avoir vouloir je vois bien
que vous avez voulu me parler comme
année alors pardonnez moi l'audace d'un
conseil tout ce mouvement tout cette
malveillance autour de vous dans la
ville
mac y est il sain sans doute prudent que
quelques torts du moins vous ne vous
exposiez pas puis songez-vous je suis
médecin il y a un peu partout ici comme
dans la campagne des malheureux qui mais
espérons demain
et puis que risquerait ge il est vrai
que vous devez connaître votre propre
destin
détrompez vous si je l' ai aperçu et
transcrit je n'ai pas su le reconnaître
c'est une faveur que dieu m'accorde pas
souvent
eh bien vous êtes blessé n'ayant n'a pas
monsieur de notre dame
je vous prie de nous pardonner cette
méchante et monsieur bonnet voici en
pleine campagne lot rien vu ce que ça
signifie mais peut-être même pas vous
écoutez de telles méthodes ne s'ennuyait
pas monsieur de nostredame il nous
fallait vous entretenir de choses graves
curieuse endroit pour le faire ma maison
que je sache est ouverte à tous il n'eut
pas été sage de courir le risque de vous
comprendre que le scrupule bien excessif
ce me semble
ils peuvent paraître tel aujourd'hui
mais ne plus l'être demain non non non
mais au fait je n'ai pas choisi de
perdre mon temps avec vous comme il vous
plaira
j'irai l'ont très vite monsieur de
nostredame vous êtes détenteur d'un
secret qui pour nous est de la plus
haute importance continuer ce secret
nous devons vous demander de nous le
faire partager
voilà qui est direct et clair en effet
du moins dans l'expression car pour ce
qui est du sens de vos paroles je ne
devine pas de quel secret s'agit-il
et pourquoi devrais je vous le confirme
parce que vous êtes des nôtres
je ne vous croyais pas capable de
plaisanter sur un tel sujet parle en
francs ou ne courait aucun danger ici
raison de plus pour ne pas travestir la
vérité
les esprits les plus distingués de
l'otan sont tous venus se joindre à la
réforme
pourquoi feriez-vous exception je vote
vous voulez me flattez en même temps que
vous flatter aussi mais je suis
catholique et j'entends le rester à
montpellier toulouse agen à lyon dans
toutes les villes où vous avez séjourné
vous avez entretenu de bonnes relations
avec des calvinistes natoire comme j'en
ai toujours entretenu avec vous au salon
mais pour qu'il continue il ne faudra
pas renouveler ces rencontres de
brigands et ce tous les vrais
catholiques nos querelles et mépris pour
les luthériens des calvinistes
je prouve bien que non monsieur de
l'insondable le jour est proche où l'on
ne pourra plus être que partisan ou
ennemis et vous le savez bien bien mieux
que nous qui ne pouvons que le
déchiffrer sans certitude dans ces
prophéties vous avez brillé à dessein ce
que vous savez de notre avenir
nous y voilà donnez nous le moyen de
comprendre sans ambiguïté ce qui
concerne notre propre destin nous ne
désirons pas autre chose et regarder la
vérité en face
nous avons avec nous la fois à la
probité et le courage contre nous toutes
les forces rassemblent et de la
corruption de l'hypocrisie du pouvoir
nous donner les moyens de connaître de
quoi demain sera fait rétablir l
équilibre si je vais un jour un secret
capable de peser de quelques poids je
vous transmettrai à ceux qui viendraient
me le demander au nom de la paix et de
la justice sans arrière-pensée au roi
charles aux neuf ou à la reine-mère par
exemple s'il le fallait
nous en étions sûrs voilà le danger
contre lequel nous devons vous mettre en
garde et nous prémunir
vous êtes bien injuste envers la famille
royale voici depuis peu et grâce à elles
libres de pratiquer votre religion et
d'ouvrir vos églises dans toutes les
campagnes et ce n'est là que ruse pour
mieux nous endormir et mais nous égorger
durant notre sommeil
qu'en savez vous et vous vous qui
prétendez savoir êtes vous prêt à jurer
sur ce que vous avez le plus sacré que
le peu de liberté qu'on nous offre
aujourd'hui n'est pas un piège
monsieur de l'hospital a dit nous devons
abolir les dénominations diabolique du
cnoe papistes rappelons nous simplement
des chrétiens et monsieur l'hospitalet
devenu le chancelier du jeune roi ne
vous payez pas de mots dites-nous je
vous en conjure ce que vous avez lu de
notre destin si dieu vous a
véritablement donné le don de le
connaître je témoigne pour l'avenir
n'éclaire pas le présent
tiendrez-vous le même langage en face de
catherine de médicis morel seulement
l'occasion de lui parler elle viendra
salon et vous rencontrerez vous avez lu
ça dans mes écrits nous sommes bien
informés
nous avons aussi une autre partie à la
cour au je n'en doute pas monsieur je
crois que nous n'avons plus rien à nous
dire
juste assez si nous avons parlé
aujourd'hui en hommes libres de leurs
propos
il se peut qu'une prochaine fois nous
soyons des soldats ne connaissant aucun
devoir
accompagnez vous aux gens tant les
menaces à merveille monsieur de moreuil
je n'ai pas l'esprit des firmes et voilà
huit jours que vous ne cessez de me
harceler nous en prendre à mes gens de
me menacer du bûcher vous vous trompez
sur mon honneur je puis vous jurer que
nous n'avons jamais rien entrepris
contre vous mais prenez garde qu'il ne
soit trop tard
le jour où vous découvrirez qui sont
vrais ennemis
notre fils n'a rien vu il était encore à
l'école
dieu soit loué je leur ai ouvert la
porte moi même je ne pouvais pas deviner
il y avait là martino dont vous avez
sauvé la fille qui devenait aveugle
régnier qui est venu si souvent pour que
vous vérifiez cellule ça mon dieu
pourquoi ont-ils fait ça
on
ne pleurez pas ma faim puisque personne
n'a demandé son intervention de monsieur
l'abbé je ne sais pas ce qui leur est
arrivé
c'est la providence qui vous envoyer mon
père
la providence m'a conduit vers vous au
moment où je devais je venais vous voir
j'arrive de paris essayez-vous mon père
me donnez nous un bois vous êtes venus
de paris pour me voir je suis le
confesseur de la reine mon père je suis
confus nous vous offrons un bien étrange
accueil on à rennes m'a chargé de vous
remettre cette lettre vous la dirai tout
à loisir
vous y apprendrez que le roi passera par
salon lors de son voyage en provence
quel honneur
et quelle joie pour nous tous mais tout
ce chemin vous venez me l'annoncer
je suis chargée d'organiser le séjour de
leurs majestés de veiller à la totale
sécurité des lieux salon de croo est une
bonne vivent vraiment monsieur de nos
standards et je me demandais à mon père
de ne fonder pas une mauvaise opinion
sur cet incident il ne concerne que moi
cb il suffit que quelques envieux
entraîne quelques fanatiques
vous connaissez encore mieux ça à paris
il y en a partout de méchants jan25 jean
saux et méchant monfils donc dangereux
je ne m'inquiète pas trop
nous avons l'habitude d'être leurs
victimes nous ôtera de médecine et de
science soit sans doute monsieur de nos
soldats mais moi je suis chargé de la
sécurité du roi une enquête rapide et un
exemple suffiront à calmer les esprits
je n'ai martin en iraniennes sont punis
mais juge
les consuls on doit la protection mais
bien j'ai tout lieu de penser qu'ils ne
se déroberont plus j'aimerais que vous
leur en parliez dès ce soir et ce soir
j'ai demandé la réunion du conseil
je dois faire part aux notabilités des
désirs du roi mon père je ne suis pas
membre de cette assemblée il venait tout
de même je le prends sur moi
d'ailleurs il vous doivent bien cela
[Applaudissements]
obama
eh bien vous voyez que tout est calme
merci tout de même d'avoir bien voulu
m'accompagner en très vite maintenant
une envie de vous attendre un peu vous
n'y songez pas dieu sait à quelle heure
je vais sortir de là allez bonne nuit
je vais commencer par le relire la
lettre de la reine ça fera son petit
effet
et remonte c'est d'inventer
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'inventeur
laissez moi monsieur pour comme
poursuivez vous vous reconnaissez voyons
je suis chavigny un peu les boules
nous étions ensemble élèves de
l'astrologue général vous êtes fous là
c'est moi vous aidiez à l'argentin je
n'ai jamais entendu ce nom et je vous
prie de me laisser aller
je suis certainement vous si vous n'êtes
pas d'armes mais laissez moi voici
monsieur et dans quels termes d'une trop
grande bonté notre reine très vénérés a
bien voulu répondre à la lettre que
j'avais pris la liberté dû adresser
apprenant la venue prochaine du roi dans
notre province
ce que je viens de vous lire comble nos
voeux les plus chers et toutes vos
espérances
monsieur l'abbé bernard dit nous avait
déjà fait part de l'intention de notre
roi très chrétien de séjourner dans
notre ville nous vous remercions de nous
avoir donné confirmation de cette
heureuse nouvelle
et c'était tout naturel et l'audace
d'écrire à sa majesté que pressé pas
vous et à ce propos je me rappelle quand
à moi vous avoir demandé à l'époque
d'intervenir dans un tout autre domaine
je ne voit malheureusement pas que vous
ayez aussi bien tenu votre promesse
monsieur de nostredame voyons nous
faisons tout ce qui est en votre pouvoir
oui je sais je me demande s'il ne serait
pas grand temps de faire un peu plus est
ce que monsieur de nostredame pourrait
quitter un instant ce ton subtilement
allusif dont il a le secret pour dire
clairement de quoi il se plaint vous
tenez vraiment ce que je vous fasse
souvenir que je suis est depuis fort
longtemps victimes dans cette ville de
sarcasme et de calomnies nous
très tôt mais il ne nous appartient pas
de changer l'opinion que certains
peuvent avoir de vos travaux et nouveau
écrit même quand des détracteurs sans
vergogne public en accusation mensongère
on les proclamant ouvertement jusqu'aux
portes des églises
chacun est libre de tenter de convaincre
le plus grand nombre de gens qu'aurions
nous y voit un autre ex d'hypocrisie
vous avez complaisamment laisser se
développer toute une cabale jusqu'au
violence que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
et voilà qui est intolérable mais ceci
est une autre histoire et en quoi je
vous prie permettez que je réponde
monsieur je crains de monsieur de
nostredame oublier un peu le point de
départ de toute cette agitation
contient-il la moindre attaque envers
qui que ce soit il renferme bon nombre
d'enfants ce métier de notre dame quant
au bon sens car on est même un bon
d'autres opinions personnelles monsieur
mon confrère il se trouve que le nombre
de ceux qui la partagent va croissant
dieu merci on s'irrite de voir ainsi les
bonnes moeurs ou tragique on s'emporte
on nous accuse de complaisance
si vous voulez connaître mon opinion
messieurs elle n'est pas un verre qui
pense monsieur nostra des travers qui
s'il vous plaît nous allons messieurs
les sens là non je vous demande pardon
non non non ce serait trop facile
puisque je suis ici ou très
exceptionnellement est bien vide ont
justement l'abcès que notre vertu et
médecins s'explique si c'est seulement
de quoi je veux parler
j'avoue le pauvre et sans mal auriez
vous cherchez des leçons dans mais
maintenant je veux garder bien jusqu'ici
de les lire
j'en ai pris connaissance séjour afin de
savoir si ce qu'on prétendait s'y
trouvait réellement dans un ppp d'alcoa
et vous n'avez pas manqué de les trouver
avec horreur et au centuple j ai lu
messieurs et dans tous ses détails
l'art et la manière de composer des
pastilles magique pour s'assurer
frauduleusement les faveurs d'une
personne du sexe et ce n'est qu'un
exemple
il ne nous reste plus qu'à souhaiter à
nous qui compte des jeunes filles parmi
nos enfants que mon éminent confrère
soit un charlatan et savez vous comment
ce filtre diabolique s'administre en le
déposant avec la langue dans la bouche
de la personne dont on veut disposer
soyons sérieux quand on en est à cette
intimité voix n'est besoin qu on y
ajoute mai
s'il file trop non vos filles sont déjà
pu vous avez tort dorine il faut que
monsieur de nostredame nous dise s'il
n'y a dans ces recettes que trop pris
pour le pauvre monde ou si ce n'est pas
de la pure sorcellerie
monsieur de nostredame pouvez vous
répondre je me demande lequel de ces
messieurs entretien des capucins pour
prêcher contre moi sud la strata le
simple pirouette pour ne pas répondre je
n'ai pas à me défendre en face de gens
de mauvaise foi belle échappatoire et
vous que faites vous depuis dix minutes
si ce n'est vous échapper car enfin la
seule question est de savoir si oui ou
non vous êtes capable de garantir la
sécurité des biens et des gens dans
votre ville comme il vous est choix le
reste n'est pas votre compétence nous
n'avons jamais fui une responsabilité
nous mettrons tout en oeuvre pour vous
protéger et par la même occasion
rétablir le calme dans les airs oui vous
le ferez enfin parce que des nécessités
plus grande vie oblige
parce qu'on vous a dit que le roi ne
prendrait pas le risque inutile de
s'attarder dans une cité sans discipline
je trouve bien regrettable monsieur de
nostredame que vous vous décidez à lire
c'est injuste mouvement de mauvaise
humeur lorsque monsieur le confesseur de
la reine nous fait l'honneur d'assister
à notre réunion toute gestion est
difficile et 5 chacun puisse en discuter
sans doute monsieur de notre dame serait
t'il apaisé s'il connaissait les mesures
que vous comptez prendre posteront des
gars de devant sa maison afin que ne se
renouvellent pas les actes de violence
de ce jour en contrepartie nous
demanderons un monsieur de nostredame de
ne plus tenter de vendre c'est al mana
et nous lui conseillons de ne plus
quitter son domicile jusqu'à ce que nous
ayons la certitude que des troubles ne
se renouvelle rompu cette année
quel aveu d'impuissance et de partialité
ne comptez pas sur moi messieurs
poursuivant ce bon conseil adieu
monsieur monsieur ne vous y trompez pas
vous devez vous conformer à notre
décision mais pas le droit de manquer
c'est d'exercer mon art il ne manquera
pas de médecin pour s'occuper de vos
malades ou peut-être qu'ils ne soignent
et que les bien portants par peur de la
contagion m'insulter jamais eu l'honneur
de vous rencontrer là où sévissent et la
peste ce que je n'ai jamais cherché à
gruger des maris bon en leur vendant des
trois inutile mais vous on sait bien que
tout vous est bon pour amasser de l'or
est encore plus d'or vos accusations
sont 1 10 voilà plus de vingt ans que je
suis dans ce qu'on sait et je sais bien
qu'on n'a jamais fait appel en vain à la
générosité de lost rgam il a financé de
son argent bien des entreprises
d'intérêt public qui la sppe l'oeuvre
des bénéfices qu'il en a retiré il n'a
fait que recueillir le fruit de sa
confiance ne vous donnez pas tant de
peine monsieur pour les ramener à la
raison
la vérité c'est que ma réputation et ma
fortune les font crever de jalousie tous
autant qu'ils sont ça suffit monsieur
nostra
quand même pas ce qu'il dit propos
d'ivrogne seulement d'une langue de ton
vin vous vivez celui de vos vignes de
l'acheter si toi tu trouverais ça pour
ça c'est à ces messieurs nous n'avons
plus rien à nous dire
en effet vous ne pouvez descendre plus
bas
puissiez-vous mon père oublier le triste
spectacle que nous venons de vous donner
j'en ai honte pour ces messieurs
vous avez tout de même attendu chavigny
merci vous ne savez pas quel plaisir
vous faites alors j'ai eu doublement
raison car j'ai fait une curieuse
découverte
moi aussi chavigné moi aussi une triste
découverte et je ne suis que le petit
fils d'un marchand juif du ghetto
d'avignon j'aurais pu finir par oublier
que je n'étais pas né dans leur ville
mais bâtir une fortune espérer non quand
on n'est pas de leur race voilà ce
qu'ils me pardonneront jamais le livre
de vos profits si témoignera le vos dons
jusqu'à la fin des temps les hommes de
ma voix rendront justice
je pensais aux efforts de mes parents
pour essayer d'échapper à cette cage on
va faire nos semblables
mon grand-père abjurant la foi de ses
ancêtres et prenant ce nom de nostredame
qui était celui du quartier où il
habitait je vous révèle un étrange passé
dont vous ne vous doutiez pas
je vois qu'il vous choque je vous laisse
libre de juger si vous devez le publier
non non vous vous méprenez c'est
seulement ce mot l'abjuration qui ne
gêne là qu'est la clé indispensable pour
ouvrir la porte de la prison mais la
fois tout ceci ne vous offusquez pas
même dix pas faire bon marché de ses
croyances
je me suis déjà posé cette question
c'est peut être aussi la plus grande
preuve de confiance en dieu savoir qu on
leur trouvera toujours où que l'on aille
il m'appartient pas de juger mon grand
père vendait des légumes
mon père a pu être notaire et épousé la
fille d'un médecin de saint rémy et me
voilà moins portés sans trop de peine
jusqu'au rang que j'occupe aujourd'hui
et voulant faire plus pour leurs
souvenirs et pour ma fierté
quel meilleur roman je pouvais je leur
rendre que de renouer avec notre plus
lointain secret pourquoi leur hostilité
at elle attendu aujourd'hui pour écrêter
ils ont dû venir me supplier d'écrire à
la reine dans leurs craintes que charles
de l'offre les ignore et vous avez
obtenu sans peine ce qui le souhaitaient
bon ils me feront payer mais ce qu'ils
ne savent pas c'est que je suis est
depuis fort longtemps prêt à supporter
toute leur humiliation ne parlait pas si
je le veux le faut pour que mon fils
atteignent enfin à toutes ces dignité
comme on refusera toujours moi je ne
compte plus mais lui plus tard pour être
à leur place
consul de cette ville se peut que toute
l'ambition du vieil homme que je suis se
résume à st mais vous avez raison n'en
parlons plus est sans importance
je ne vous ai pas laisser raconter votre
histoire
alors cette étrange découverte miens
ingénieux monsieur de chevigny vous
pensez donc que toutes ces
manifestations d'hostilité serait en
quelque sorte faut monter de l'extérieur
je pense que monsieur d'armand ta venue
de paris sachant qu'il y avait un salon
quelques jaloux écueil qu'il pourrait
exciter contre monsieur de notre dame
oui il aurait donc profité d'un certain
climat disant qu'il aurait souffler sur
des braises presque éteinte mais dans
quel but
voyons monsieur l'abbé vous connaissez
aussi bien que moi le petit monde des
astrologues de la cour
j'ai été le condisciple de monsieur
darmenton il est possédé d'une telle
ambition que ses seuls mérites si grand
soit il ne saura lui suffire en quelque
sorte il est chercheur est discrédité
monsieur de nostredame
pour l'empêcher de bénéficier à sa place
de la saveur royal le grand âge de
gondoles filet sera bientôt vacante la
place d'astrologues de la reine alors
tellement invraisemblable mais non
monsieur de cheville vous êtes un
excellent connaisseur de l'âme humaine
l'ennui vrai c'est que votre capucins
menait déjà campagne avant que je ne
quitte paris et que monsieur darmenton
est l'une des dernières personnes que
j'ai rencontrées dès demain j'aurai du
mal à croire tout autre que vous allez
vous avez tout simplement été victime
d'une ressemblance votre imagination a
fait dresse de nous en blâme pas je me
serais tout aussi bien laisser prendre
si vous découvrez quelques autres fait
plus probant manquera pas de vous en
informer nous rapporter l'est plutôt au
consul je m'en garderais bien le père de
voir mes intentions se retourner contre
monsieur de nostredame non tout ceci est
bien fâché mais qui pouvons-nous je vous
trouve bien résigné monsieur l'abbé il
me semble que catherine de médicis a
nettement marqué son intention de
s'entretenir avec notre prophète
quelle sera sa réaction quand elle sera
comment on traite un homme qu'il désire
honoré alors monsieur de chavigny la
reine est trop bonne politique pour
faire passer une curiosité personnel
avant l'intérêt du royaume je vous dire
qu'elle pourrait renoncer à rencontrer
nostradamus faire cesser tous sujets de
discorde dans le royaume
n'est-il pas le but du voyage croyants
ce serait une grande injustice sans
doute sans doute mais nous n'en sommes
pas là voyez vous je trouve que les
consuls ont agi sagement en brillant
monsieur de notre-dame de ne plus
quitter son domicile on évitera ainsi
tout incident
et quand le roi viendra les esprits
seront peut-être apaisé et monsieur de
nostredame y viva je crois bien mauvais
caractère et je compte sur votre amitié
pour lui faire entendre raison
sinon sinon que voulez-vous que je vous
dise
les responsabilités sont bien lourde et
je ne suis pas le maître ici
vous pouvez revenir monsieur davantage
je ne vous fais pas mes compliments il
me semble pourtant n'avoir pas si mal
mal au vol oui mais vous vous êtes et
sait reconnaître ce qui est la pire des
sottises ça pouvait s'imaginer que je
tomberai sursaut xavi ni quel besoin y
est vous d'aller rôder autour de cette
maison il reçoit vous avait prévenus que
notre dame il vient d'adopter cei
justement je voulais le voir le voir
mais vous devenu fou mais non seulement
rencontré son regard ne serait ce qu'une
seconde lire dans ses yeux il est pascal
de padt moi ça monsieur d'un mental que
dois je comprendre que cherchez-vous
nous y croyez au prophète nostradamus
je croyais que les augures souriait
quand ils se croisaient dans la rue vous
avez le mépris si l'on remet vous
m'amusez quelle vérité avait voulu dans
les yeux de monsieur notre dame une
étrange lumière c'est le cas l'une a
peur peut-être un crois pas vous
maquetter mais cela ne change rien bien
au contraire
que dois je faire maintenant non vous
plus rien votre légèreté m'oblige à agir
seul vignoble nostradamus comme prévenus
dont sa propre maintenant il sera dans
salon je ne serai sûr de rien à moins
qu'il me dise ce que j'attends de lui
avant l'arrivée de leurs majestés
imaginez-vous catherine de médicis le
faisant libérer pour son bon plaisir
monsieur lamentin la reine a des raisons
personnelles de rencontrer le prophète
tout comme vous avez des raisons
personnelles de vouloir empêcher cette
rencontre est bon monsieur l'abbé moi je
ne fais que servir dieu et son église
[Applaudissements]
et hier étaient désertés
- je suis de nostredame le fer et le feu
le sang et les larmes
comme vous l'avez bien imaginer c'est à
venir ténébreux que l'homme se prépare
après grand or du pain plus grand sabre
est le grand moteur les siècles
renouvelle pluie s'enlève famine fait
rep est au ciel vu feu courant longue
est un seul je vois mon père que vous
connaissez bien mais prophétie savez
vous que cela m'a permis de prendre bien
souvent votre défense je vous en
remercie il faut quelques mérites
c'était dans des cercles d'hommes de
lettres et de poser ce prix je répondais
ceux qui vous accusent écrire d'une pub
rugueuse qu'il y avait la volonté de pau
est de capter l'attention en oeuvre tant
l'imagination 1 par gandhi score la
trombe tremblera accords rompus dressant
la tête au ciel bouge sanglant dans le
ciel hazra au sol
l'afa soientt de lait et de bienne il
faut une sorte de génie pour brutaliser
si heureusement notre langue
cetto nostra
pourquoi n'avoir pas fait tout
simplement confiance à votre talent vous
preniez un bien grand risque en menant
cette fureur poétique pour parole divine
vous le voyez aujourd'hui il ne va
jamais y avoir de risque à dire ce qu
est pas de cela entre nous puisque je
m'avoue votre admirateurs mais je
n'entends pas qu'on loue mais vers mon
père je veux qu'on sache que j'ai
seulement tenté d'exprimer de mon mieux
ce que dieu a voulu que je déchiffre des
temps à venir
vous n'allez pas prétendre que les 2,4
un vague que je viens de citer recèle un
sens caché mais ils n'ont pas d'autre
raison d'être
je vous mets au défi de les livrer en
clair et vous savez bien excellence en
cette obscure c'est qu'il faut protéger
la révélation et la rendre supportable
est rempli il y à la vérité de poète
libre à vous de ne pas me croire mais je
crois que demain sera telle que vous
l'imaginez
tout comme je ne puis croire que l'on
fait le paradis sont telles que donc
nous les a décrits dans cette divine
comédie ça ne suffit pas alors écrivez
moi il me suffirait d'une petite lueur
il ne vous en coûterait rien à quoi bon
je ne vous crois pas si facile à
convaincre
dommage pour qu'ils en créent tvous par
charité pour vous monsieur de nostredame
que d'inquiétudes me cause votre
obstination inquiétudes vraiment un jour
on vous demande de prouver que vous êtes
un vrai prophète en f1 je ne saurais le
faire ni halak mystère divine volonté
inexplicable incompréhensible et pour
moins tout autant que pour vous on
pourrait voir les choses autrement
il peut y avoir mystère dans la façon
dont le seigneur nous transmet ces
révélations mais la leçon doit être
clair pour tous ces mois serviteur j'ai
peur sur notre dame que l'orgueil ne
vous fait jouer un rôle qui n'est pas
celui attendu de vous vous êtes un
messager qui égarent les mici vous
cacher un secret qui ne vous appartient
pas ne comprenez vous pas que votre
devoir est de nous transmettre tout ce
que vous savez il m'avait semblé vous
avoir entendu dire que je mettais qu un
rêveur vous m'avez peut-être convaincu
du contre d'ailleurs qu importe mon
opinion l'église romaine doit faire face
aujourd'hui à la plus redoutable des
hérésies
si dieu a choisi ce moment vous parler
c'est qu'il entend que par votre bouche
tout son église sont informés traduisez
en langage clair ces prophéties ou
prenez garde
à quoi mon père a mérité le sceau des
prophètes du diable j'ai confiance en
celui qui m'inspire vous ne manquerez
pas l'accusateur je trouverais aussi des
défenses et la reine
par exemple la reine pourra témoigner
des quelques vérités que j'ai cru devoir
lui révéler alors monsieur de notre-dame
payez-vous de dupes et oubliez vous que
je suis son confesseur vous savez dans
ce que je lui ai prédit que ses quatre
fils règne et je n'appelle pas ça une
prophétie et un diagnostic le médecin
que vous êtes sait fort bien que la
phtisie consume les derniers débats loin
si je veux voir la reine c'est que j'ai
d'autres choses plus importantes à lui
dire
il est de votre devoir de me permettre
de lui parler alors confié vous à moi et
si je juge que cela en vaut la peine de
ferait en sorte que malgré toutes les
difficultés vous puissiez la rencontre
et ne vous écoute
le message ne concerne que l'on va
lasser mais j'ai de notre-dame renoncer
à cette comédie avant qu'elle ne tourne
au tragique
ou bien vous êtes comme je le pense un
bon riemer doublé d'un habile marchands
ou bien ou bien le tribunal de la sainte
inquisition devra un jour décider de
l'identité de celui qui vous inspire
vous ai dit que j'avais confiance en
dieu ou trois confiance en vous même
mais en ce qui concerne catherine de
médicis j'aime autant vous enlever toute
illusion vous la verrez pas les consuls
craignant pour votre sécurité ont décidé
de vous mettre à l'abri au château de
béroul vous serez asie hors de la ville
pendant la visite des souverains mais
roulent mais c'est une prison personne
n'a le droit de me contraindre à quitter
salon c'est un déni de justice
mais rouler un lieu où vous serez bien
protégés on vous y conduira demain dans
la matinée vous y resterez que le temps
du séjour royal trois petits jours on
voir monsieur de nostredame je vais
prier pour que dieu vous est clair si
vous désirez me parler l'un des gardes
de votre peau retira me chercher à toute
heure de la nuit il y a dans mon sens du
riz 16 4 1 où apparaît le nom du grand
pontife et 14 où se trouve le mot
huguenots je les ai comptés je ne vous
demande que la traduction de cela en
échange je ferai beaucoup beaucoup peau
que pourriez-vous faire noter les
savoirs et voici insensé pour imaginer
pouvoir changer les desseins de dieu
s'il vous était contraire et vous
monsieur de nos soldats elle vous assez
naïf pour croire que quelques mots de
vous contrarierait sa volonté
vous êtes tout l'opposé d'un naïf vous
m'avez très bien compris la nuit vous
portera conseil si demain matin à 6
heures je n'ai rien de vous il sera trop
tard
mais je suis persuadé que vous aurez à
coeur de ne pas me faire manquer
[Musique]
romain positif garde de t'approcher de
la cité que de fleurs aux tons sans
viendra auprès de la cre a chez toi et
les tiens
à la rose
[Musique]
pour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'est rien passé la nuit a été
tranquille elle
vous êtes venus nombreux pour la relève
[Musique]
ce n'est même pas pris une heure de
sommeil ils sauront jamais vous dire
combien votre amitié une touche je vous
l'aurais plus efficace je sais que votre
présence ou d'un grand rex
j'ai tout tenté cette nuit pour le
persuader
il faut vous lui parlez à votre tour
maintenant que vous écoutera je n'ai
rien à lui demander je montrais jusqu'au
allait l'entraîner sur l'intransigeance
ce soir on emmènera pourrait quitter
cette maison ou bien seront peut être
confisqué vos enfants n'auront plus de
fortune je le sais bien
tout ceci est sûre il connaît le moyen
d'échapper à ce destin juste et en hard
il va demander la transcription en clair
que de quelques prophecies ce voile qui
cache le sens de ces prédictions dieu le
veut il se serait un péché un crime que
les cartes et sans doute
mais
mais il peut jouer de cette obscurité
est donnée à ceux qui le persécutent
déloyalement la peinture qu'il mérite
pour l'amour de vous si voulant prier
ne tardez pas il attend peut-être qu'un
sind où il est resté dans cette ville
qu'il n'aimait pas et qui ne l'aimaient
pas parce que c'était la mienne et pour
que ces enfants connaissent un jour la
fierté d'être les premiers citoyens du
pays où ils sont nés tout ce qu'il a
fait il l'a toujours fait pour nous et
j'irai maintenant augmenter son chagrin
en lui laissant croire que je ne
comprends pas le sacrifice qu'il
s'impose non non lui seul sait ce qui
est bien
vous m'obligez à prononcer des paroles
cruel le stagiaire de vie ou de mort
j'aurais honte de le pousser à maintenir
les mots ne sortirait pas de ma bouche
je donnerai tout pour qu'il retrouve la
paix on me semble que si j'obtenais de
lui qu'il livre de faux semblants pour
parole divine je le perdrai pour
l'éternité
allez vous avez donc une telle foi en
moi
je ne comprends pas le sens de ces
épreuves que dieu nous envoie
mais je sens à boulons et je sais que
nous le sommes nous étions si heureux
êtes vous sûr qu'on puisse tenter exiger
de nous
tout ça n'a aucun sens c'est ce que vous
me disiez cette nuit chevigny
pardonnez-moi si votre femme qui a
raison la crac m'avait fait oublier
qu'ils vous étiez
oh
préparez un peu fouillis conserver le
ap
super aux valeurs ne résistez pas vous
allez provoquer les pires années trompez
pas oui mais ce sont des infirmes
il fallait à tout prix entrer on veut
nous insérer sur de nostredame pourquoi
des soldats devant votre vaisseau
blessés les entrées m'apportera toujours
été ouverte
ils ne comprendraient pas on l'a
désordre mais pas celui de m'empêcher
d'être charitable allait entrer à donner
l'heure ce qui nous reste
d'où venez vous et vous allez-vous mes
amis nous traversons la ville pour aller
au devant du roi pour percevoir les
premiers aumône
asseyez vous vivez et mangez vous ne
marcherez que mieux
[Musique]
vous ne mangez pas il ne peut rien
avaler il dit que la gorge lui brûle
mais
j'ai un message pour vous vénérable
frère
c'est mon ami on avait donc besoin de
rien j'ai besoin que votre très
glorieuse majesté me conserve le plus
précieux de ses trésors sa confiance
qui êtes vous celui qui vous a prédit
que vous seriez roi vous n'étiez alors
qu'un enfant au berceau et votre mémoire
a pu oublier les traits du prophète
nostradamus
on a une bien étrange tenue même pour le
métro
on ne m'a pas permis d'en choisir une
autre pour venir au devant de mai
s'ouvre mais elle me convient je suis le
plus humble de vos serviteurs votre
attention nous touche monsieur le préfet
vous connaissez aussi mes frères
monsieur de nostredame je salue avec un
style du du maine et le duc d'alençon
le troisième qui fait la mauvaise tête
mon cousin berne
il est de méchante humeur depuis qu'il y
ait un coup de vent l'a obligé à les
rechercher son château jusque dans une
église
il est du parti de la réforme laissé la
bride de votre cheval à monsieur de
nostredame il n'y a pas de sage plus
dignes de vous conduire
[Musique]
rejoindre le salon en crèveront de
jalousie et de notre dame de bonne
guerre c'est malheureux à quoi faut-il
allusion
je ne le sais déjà plus madame vous
savez bien que les mémoires que pour
l'avenir
au toit créatures plus que parfaite en
jeu mais s'agit de celui qui est au
commencement et la fin de toutes choses
je t'adore de rompre son silence et de
me dire si le jour est venu d'apporter
clairement un mortel
l'aide de la révélation
les hommes vénérable qui passent leur
vie en quête de la sagesse me l'ont
conseillé
mais comment puis-je savoir si cette
femme ray les maires qui par mois un
terreau ange est plus préoccupé du
bonheur des hommes que du triste destin
de sa race
est il temps de parler
faut-il encore se tait
[Musique]
qu'avez-vous juin monsieur de nostredame
insensé qui demandent à connaître le
destin de tes fils fou celui qui le
dirait qu'elle est volume c'est
d'ailleurs ce tram
j'ai vu j'ai vu la couronne royale sur
la tête du jeune henry berne
cette nouvelle révélation gelé comprise
comme un signe qui venait à son honneur
voilà pourquoi je n'ai pas obéir votre
vue vénérable maître au delà de
l'obéissance pour la dette accompli il
ya la conscience vous m'avez aidé à
tromper la surveillance de mes gardiens
pour que je parle dans l'arène éprouve
hjira catherine de médicis que cet égard
sans rémission n'est pas loin et qu un
bourbon de l'église réformée deviendrait
henry le quatrième j'ai gardé le silence
et apaiser sa curiosité par d'astrologie
conseil vous avez agi sagement la reine
n'aurait pas supporté ce destin sans
tenter par tous les moyens de le
détourner et alors alors vénérable
maître loeb ne pourra jamais répondre à
de telles questions
sauf peut-être le dernier celui à qui
s'adresse sans doute le message du
prophète dans sa totalité
celui qui s'ouvre à l'esprit à la fin de
notre cycle le dernier grand monarque
l'an 1999 dernier de notre ère quand du
ciel descendra
le grand roi des frais gunner ne devrait
pas tarder je ne saurais vous dire
d'habitude coupe à ses habitudes pour un
médecin
la naissance et la mort n'ont pas de
bonnes habitudes je pourrais revenir un
peu plus tard mais je veux être le
premier avait annoncé la nouvelle
patientez encore un moment asseyez vous
monsieur le consul
merci c'est un honneur qui rejaillit sur
nous tous c'est le propre des grands
hommes d'éclairer de leur rayonnement
les ténèbres qui les entoure vous êtes
là monsieur le consul rien de fâcheux
j'espère rien que du ru
voilà qui nous changera monsieur de
nostredame eu la grande joie de vous
annoncer que par décret royal
vous venez d'être faits médecin
ordinaire du roi avec tous les
privilèges afférents à ce titre c'est en
effet une belle nouvelle qui me comble
vous savez que la reine on a fini avec
toutes les affaires qui la retenait en
provence elle a quitté ex ou la paix
revenue dans les esprits elle s'arrêtera
à arles dernière étape sur la route du
languedoc
c'est là qu'elle souhaite que le roi
puisse vous remettre cet illustre titre
et le conseil de salon unanime unanime a
chargé de vous transmettre ses
félicitations et ses voeux est prié de
vous demander d'être notre représentant
auprès de leurs majestés pour leur
présenter nos devoirs au moment du
départ
puis je compte sur vous pour cette
ambassade abassan non
nous comptons bien sûr vous n'est ce pas
oui je vais vous laisser je comprends
que cet honneur vous causent quelques
émotions
je vous laisse à votre satisfaction
madame monsieur je vous accompagne
qu'avez-vous
venez jalinier
je
non
m
il a dit l'ambassade
le mot est juste ce sera une ambassade
nous voilà rendus au terme de ma vie
cheville cette grande faveur de dieu
n'accorde que c'est rarement
il vient de me la faire je connais le
earth reproche où je vais devoir
paraître devant lui
petit fou souvenez-vous dernier 80 des
présages de retour d'ambassade trouver
tous morts près du lit et du bon le 2
juillet 15 166 nostradamus était trouvé
mort à côté de son lit tout près d'un
banc de bois
le dernier 4-1 des présages disait du
retour d'ambassade dont du roi mise aux
lieux plus n'en fera sera allé à dieu
par en plus proches amis frères du sang
trouvé tous morts près du lit et du banc
trente deux ans plus tard césar de
nostredame son fils était élue premier
consul de salon de croo
[Musique]
bon
où
vous
[Musique]
oh
hautmont
[Musique]
oh